Roy you're working later you and Angela  visiting franksen Kowski tonight  one more thing no God what nobody should  get hurt bad  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  why this men wanna cave who's like some  kind of setup how'd you find yourself  there tonight one thing we can do now  get as far out as possible can you stop  the orange for me  why how doesn't it do something there's  people looking for us the you're  bringing her into that you think about  that you want to leave it's okay a  little wimp deserves better than this  thank you  [Music]  but I got something going on I could  even help you out a little bit give the  to your life  [Music]  [Music]  look the pass isn't real  you remember how you want to remember it  [Music]  you